خليني اخدك عبد الله الموضوع الثاني اللي
هو تحدثنا عنه حتى انا وانت وكنا تكلمنا
انه في مشكله كمان اخطر جلسه بتواجه توتير
يبدو انها مشكله تقنيه او في مشكله انه
بتخرج الناس وما بيقدروا يرجعوا يدخلوا
ثاني على حساباتهم اذا تشرح لنا شيء اللي
بيصير وايش سببها
السعوديه وفي بعض الدول حول العالم اي شخص
رابط
لذلك ضروري ضروري ضروري انك انت ما تسوي
تسجيل خروج اذا انت مفعل خاصيه التحققتين
لانه قد ما تستطيع انك تعود للمراه نهائيا
اذا انت قادر توصل لحسابك وقادر
خاصيه التحقق بخطوتين عن طريق الجوال
وتعتمد على التطبيقات مثل جوجل
الميزه اللي موجوده
حجه الايفون ان انت تقدر تربط الحساب
فيديو هيك اللي انت نشرته كنت بك كمان
بتحكي فيه عن هذه المشكله بس يعني انه طب
اكيد الناس كتبت لتويتر على هذا الموضوع
هل كان عندهم رد هالكن في تبرير
تويتر
لكن اي شخص حاليا
في خيار في الاعدادات ووجه مشكله في
الدخول من نفس الاعدادات هذه بامك يقدم
طلب
او كود التحقيق ما يصلي والتويتر خلال همم
فتره اقل من اسبوع رحلوا يساعدوني يخلونا
يدخل مره ثانيه على حساب اوكي بس هذا ذحين
ممكن الناس يقول لك انه يربطوه مع ماسك
والجنان اللي جالس بيصير في تويتر وفي نفس
الوقت يقول لك لا هذا الشيء كل الشركات
ممكن تعاني منه
كل الشركات انستغرام
الى مميزات كثيره صارت عندهم مشاكل تقنيه
وهذا المتوقع طبيعي
في
الملصق انه بيقول همم مشتركين زادوا
هذي شي طبيعي
جدا كثيره هذا شيء ملاحظ صراحه في الفتره
الماضيه دائما الشغلات الجدليه اللي يكون
فيها جدال ايوه بس تكون فلا اتوقع اكثر
شيء او اكثر شيء صار لتويتر لما ترامب
لانهم هم اللي ساهموا في نهضه من السمره
ثانيه
عدد المتابعين كمان هو يعني احنا بنشكرك
على هذه المداخله لكن المحرر التقرير
العربيه عبد الله السبع
[موسيقى]